- So what are you holding?
- Okay, so this is for you.
It's a piece of raw Selenite.
- Oh, I love gems, I love stones, yeah--
- It's a little bit like Gypsum.
They're kind of the same thing,
but they form differently.
- Yes!
- So this refracts light
in a really cool way.
- Yes!
- So it kind of
if you look and you hold it like that,
you can see how that kinda shimmers.
- Yes!
- On the surface of that.
It's really cool, I really love it!
- I'm really into gems.
I usually, I actually wore it today.
But I have honey quartz that wear.
A quartz necklace that
I wear all the time.
Cause it's a very, it's a
very powerful stone, quartz.
- Beautiful--
- Yes!
- And in this, they say that--
- [Kelly] Thank you!
- Under the light of a full moon
and in like the--
- [Kelly] It recharges it.
- In the sun, yeah they recharge.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- They're really beautiful!
- I am a nerd with you, Sheldon.
I'm just kidding.
- I'm in to it.
- I was trying to pick out
something as beautiful as you.
I don't think I did you justice.
(audience sighs, cheers, and applauds)
- That's, that's our show.
I'm gonna go cry.
(audience applauds)
I'm fine!
- The only problem is--
- I'm fine!
- Didn't do you justice.
- Oh my Gosh!
I love you!
- [Sheldon] Thank you very--
Oh my God, I needed to hear that.
You're so kind.